was there any image this week more
powerful than this the broadcaster
Samira Ahmed heading into an employment
tribunal flanked by other women in her
industry of all races and backgrounds
United she a women of color is taking
the BBC to courts for paying her 600
percent less than a white male presenter
who anchored a similar show six hundred
percent these high-profile cases are
just the tip of the iceberg
this year the gender pay gap actually
widened for the first time in six years
with full-time workers being paid eight
point nine percent more if they're men
the figures are bad enough but that
women have to fight so hard for
something that is simple equality
beggars belief anyone who cares about
fairness needs to get on our side I care
about fairness and I care very much
about women in the workplace and I think
it is a fantastic time to be a woman in
the in the workplace we've had women in
top roles from prime ministers head of
the London Fire Brigade head of the
London met you know you near me women
can now get to the top and I really do
celebrate that so and we share we share
something there when it comes to the
gender pay gap I feel that the gender
pay gap you just referenced the
difference between a man's full-time
earnings and a woman's full-time
hominins I feel it's such a blunt
instrument that doesn't actually tell us
very much because if you go into a room
and you say men over there women over
there earnings earnings there's a
difference that really doesn't take into
account most of the things which is the
detail and the data that we should be
paying attention to which is more
relevant because first of all it's
illegal to pay people differently for
the exact same role that's the first
thing and the second thing is women
sometimes do make different choices so
there's very little pay get pay gap
between going into the world of work
until it until the age of about 40 then
it starts to widen when you look at
things like ladies and it often is
ladies take the time off works you have
a family and to raise a family or to
care for elderly relatives etc so there
are details are going in
- that that don't make the system quite
as unfair as those statistics prevent
and I always try to say that these
statistics should be taken with caution
because I don't want any young girl to
look at this statistic and think there's
no point we entering the world of work
because I'm going to be discriminated
against from day one because that's
simply not true
yes can I just give you some statistics
and I'll bring you in so just to kind of
elaborate on what my point here is the
average salary for women in the UK aged
between 15 59 is thirty two thousand and
fifty the average salary for men the
same age is forty four thousand five
hundred and sixty one pounds and you
know I'll bring you in Rachel but just
to respond to Michele I think we're
saying the same things I'm not saying
that I'm interested in the superficial
headline of what's what the pay gap is
I'm interested in the reasons that women
are chronically as the data shows being
paid less at the same level of their
career as men and the reasons are that
they're doing lots of unpaid work in the
home taking care of children taking care
of elderly relatives and it's not
necessarily a choice this labor often
falls to women it's label that is unpaid
and it's also damaging their ability to
reach their potential in the workplace
and the result is inequality now exactly
how you tackle that is a complicated
question but I I'm hoping we can accept
that that is a problem that we should
address Rachel yes I mean I think the
evidence shows that over a course of a
woman's lifetime she earns 20 percent
less than men and that is because your
your use of the word choices doesn't
hide a multitude of sins it hides it
hides a multitude of societal
expectations and injustice is when it
comes to women's work what is a woman's
work and what is a man's work and there
is still overall I think an expectation
that it's going to be women who are
going to give up their jobs to look
after short small children older
children or elderly parents and this is
my experience even though I think I've
had every advantage in my life education
I've had you know I've been the first
woman in a lot of organizations but I've
been the one who's given up my work when
I've had kids how many how could I not
by the way just when I started off there
was one other trainee who joined at the
same time as me we both have exactly the
same experience but in within
and it wasn't I promise you because he
was so much better writing about the
economy than I was he was he was his
pain was put up and I had to go to the
managing editor and I'd say why did you
page on who's now because his name was
John
why did you bump his pay up by three
grand a year and not mine and they went
well because you know John might get
married didn't have a family I said I
might get married anyway we come in as
well you know just there there is this
there's these big structure problems but
I also raised the case of Samira are men
it's not that she's been taking time off
her job to raise her kids she's doing
the same work as Jeremy buying very
comparable show not the same show but
comparable she was earning six hundred
percent less that is just naked on
fairness well I think that's theirs
we're talking about several different
things here and by the way speaking of
the person who launched legal actions at
the HRC against a very large council on
equal pay because they were paying
dinnerladies different to the guys or
and they don't let me back in the city
because they had to send they sell their
conference center to pay for the
settlement that was the right thing to
do I mean it was a right thing to do and
people shouldn't be paid differently for
the same work a pay gap thing by the way
isn't about that big
reflects the different seniority of men
and women it's a whole different story
but issue of Sameera armored which I
want to raise to be honest I'm a great
fan of Samira as I regard her as a
friend but in the same way to Miriam a
Riley case some years ago I think we
just need to step a step back a bit and
we v me to step back television
presenting is not a job yeah it is not a
job
yeah you know being a dinner lady is a
job you go through interviews you have
to have qualifications and so on being a
gardener is all of that television
presenting doesn't have what people call
job like characteristics and why I'm
worried about this focus on this issue
is that actually if you start polluting
the law by essentially making judgments
on
on this kind of thing on this kind of
thing then you weaken the case of
ordinary people who have to go into
court and make arguments about the
content of their job which is nothing
like being between ordinary people and
women like let's just see what the BBC
themselves are saying about the Sameera
case BBC News says points of view as an
entertainment program with a long
history and is a household name with the
public news watch while an important
program isn't Sameera was paid the same
as her male breed Assessor when she
began presenting news watch gender has
not been a factor in levels of pay for
points of view news and entertainment of
very different markets and pay across
the media industry reflects this as BBC
News you've got two lines running here
after one which I absolutely agree is
it's terrible when you show those
statistics how a woman through her life
or at different age bands of a load
that's absolutely wrong but I honestly
think to support Trevor's point to use
Sameera much as I like when indeed I've
worked with RHS tomorrow there's a
simple fact which the BBC has put
forward recognition of Jeremy vine is at
79%
with the general public recognition of
samara ahmed is at 29% of the general
public I don't expect to get the same
show fee on LBC where I have 1.5 million
listeners by the way I don't get the
same thing as Graham Norton gets on the
BBC with the millions and that is the
simple matter
Trevor's right you can have been a
hairdresser and you're a TV presenter
you can have been a politician you could
have been a jockey
you could have been anything you like in
your presenter so it's not the same it's
not the same in the level of training
and you will command a fee you will
command a fee by the size of your
audience that's why mr. Norton earns
quite rightly a lot more than I do per
show if you look at the recent issue
where the BBC had to overturn a
judgement it made about naga munchetty
where if she was ripped from my
for condemning racism if I hadn't been
for Samara Armand holding the head of
editorial standards to account on her
program that might not have happened the
work that she does and this isn't about
her personally this is about to
paraphrase Michelle earlier little girls
watching this program and seeing you
Trevor say that if you aspire to hold
important powerful people to account on
TV that's not a job in you don't deserve
to be paid equally and I don't think
that's a totally different category to
the work that dinner ladies or Road
sweepers or council works or factory
workers all of which are jobs I respect